[Music]
let's talk beyond the musical episode
what's coming up now we got the official
engagement on the books what's next yeah
I think with that Barry was just kind of
reestablishing his confidence in the
relationship and you know not letting
his fear dictate things but rather let
his heart kind of dictate things which
he's always done in the past so we're
kind of back to true form Barry I think
when I read The Musical and I saw that
they were going to get back together and
have such a great proposal I was super
excited with an engagement comes a
potential wedding let's start planning
this Candace well yeah I mean I can't
wait to maybe wear a wedding dress on TV
I don't think I've ever done that but
we've been moving things so far in terms
of West Island so fast
um maybe we can just like slow down on
the wedding maybe maybe next season end
of next season I don't know we got to
make sure she's alive first we got to
make sure she's alive first that's
actually very huge yeah
dream with me Candace if nothing were to
go wrong what is irises perfect day if
nothing were to go wrong um if nothing
went wrong I think ideally berry would
like to sleep in a little bit get up
have some coffee with iris she would
definitely get up go to jitters go for a
morning run because you know he'd get
some endorphins out of that he does like
running go to work have a normal work
day
maybe report on something very normal
like the water in a central city and you
know I think he likes doing some minor
saving the day like a little you know
armed robbery stopping maybe sick Grand
Theft Auto like stuff like that's fun
for him come home make dinner for her
and bury feed the turtle you're like
watch Netflix just chill exactly Netflix
and chill oh wait I didn't mean it like
that like well then probably next up
Netflix and chill and then at night hang
some Netflix and chill dude we got the
same answer for kisses mmm ah come on we
know what's up with Barry and iris
everyone they're adult why not
you